oh good thing to know that we do indeed
know our friends uh yeah we're pretty
good at this yeah we're four for four so
far yeah four for four oh I know who
this
is oh I think I know who this is as well
yeah I know who this is yeah I know who
this is wait hold on yeah oh oh yeah
yeah my bad my bad yeah wait what we
have three people left shindo Sydney and
Kaho one of them doesn't make sense but
I'm pretty sure the rest is all right
wait no this one's I actually don't know
this one
this could be any of them no really yes
I know who this
is okay should we go in 3 2
1 okay I'm going to take a guess okay
ready 3 2 one Sydney okay okay um
anohana and Oro yeah okay I I looked at
like Aken kamakani like anohana or the
[__] is that aen artart I just saw that
why does everyone have the most giant
tars aen is a one of the worst anime
ever made be one of the funniest shows
because it's just so bad so so I I
remember so the reason I know this was
because she obviously told me to this uh
told me uh the shows to put on uh I
noted down on some things about why
they're on there as well because I she
was saying some of this sh see she was
saying some of this [__] the the first
show she says is Naruto and I'm like
I've been with you for 10 years we are
married now I didn't even know you
watched Naruto I I was yes I I was I
think she was just trying to please her
husband with she was like what the [__]
you've watched Naruto Sydney we've been
married and she was like yeah uh this
was this was her first anime uh and it
was the very first time she felt
Goosebumps watching uh watching any
Shonen or any show in general uh she
talks about the rock Le versus gar fight
and I'm like
excuse me how how have you never talked
to me about this you've never referenced
taking off the weights yeah you've never
referenced taking off the weights you
know you you clown on everyone who
watches Naruto and uh and uh so that was
the biggest kind of like surprise for me
so aen what is this show about other
than big tits so aen is a show from the
early 2000s in one or two episode OVA if
I remember correctly um and it's uh said
in high school yeah um and it is one of
the most
overtly over sexualized overreacted just
like comedy shows I guess imagine if uh
fan service characters were some
lovecraftian nightmare
creatures that's aen because you look at
their like you look at their tits and
it's it's like it's it's it goes beyond
not even knowing how the female anatomy
works yeah it's it's I just remember the
character the the the character with
like literally the biggest pair of tits
I've ever seen in my life like it's like
the size of her entire body yeah and
they they go full jiggle physics with it
as fck jump R scene yeah uh and uh
Sydney told me that this is on there
because this is the very first etchy
show that she watched this this this was
the very first ety show that she watched
stumble across this I never even heard
of this show this is such an Infamous
show yeah because this show got Infamous
because of the tits like you go on like
any forums and someone would have uh
like some sort of like GIF of one of the
girls with her tits like [__]
flopping about I I want check this out
on YouTube please watch any scene from
you'll be like what the [__] is going on
definitely going to get age restricted
if we show any Clips on here but she
told me that this was the first etchy
show she ever watched and she was and
she was so terrified that her dad would
find out what she was watching that she
literally system rebooted her entire
computer after watching
aen I mean you know that's a great
[__] choice you know I I would I
would I think I would just smash my
computer with a hammer what the [__]
yeah yeah which scene are you watching
there just like the boobs are like
sentient things
yeah yep yep that's the scene that's the
scene I remember that is the scene
that's the scene I remember what the
heck I was going to make a video on this
show years ago and I was like I don't
think I can without getting like [__]
Community guidelines stried for showing
anything okay see I looked at this 3x3
and the reason why I got confused is
because of Bobo same me bro same I have
I had I [__] love Bobo and Sydney and
I have never talked about B T's never
mentioned this to me either what the
[__] no way she's watched bbo yeah she
[__] when she that was actually that
was the second thing she said after
Naruto she was like Naruto B cuz uh uh
yeah those Bo I don't [__]
know do not put disrespect on my man's
name I [__] no it is one of the
funniest manga series I've ever read
I'll be I'll be honest I haven't seen it
it was it's so [__] funny so what was
the reasoning for putting it on list uh
that it was Naruto and
B however did it say it
the b b boo uh those were like just her
two childhood animes huge on Cartoon
Network I remember like the dub was
really popular overseas yeah I think
Naruto and bobao I didn't know this
because in England we did not get bobao
at all at all uh so Naruto I knew about
but I didn't know that was like widely
spread on television as well yeah um
Bobo is just the most like if you took
every kind of poo poo pee PE humor and
threw it into I think I think the I
think the original manga was like almost
30 CH 30 volumes um but it is oh my God
like this is still to this day one of
the most absurd yet hilarious comedy
shows and the and the anime as well is
really [__] funny as well yeah
obviously Orin High School Host Club
that checks out that that is like that
checks out hello I have just it I have
just discovered my first uh shjo anime
Anana checks out I think I've heard
Sydney sing the ending more than I've
actually heard the actual ending do you
think does bring up an yeah yeah do you
think anah would have aged well at all
um oh that's a good
question uh I watched it and when I
watched it I was like this is a show
that I never ever want to watch again so
I'll never find out I just I just never
wanted to watch it again I mean I for
one if I needed if I needed to cry I
would put on anah yeah I for one [__]
loved this show when I watched it uh
cried like a baby at the end beautiful
music as well opening an Banger um I
don't know if I would recommend it to
people today though I know right it's
hard I think I think it's really like I
think people who watch it now some
people will like really [__] connect
to it and then others will be like this
is so cheesy I'm scared to rewatch it
because I hold it really really close to
my heart it's it's the the vibe of the
show is everything that I love but at
the same at the same time I think back
to it and I'm like a lot of this I love
the crying the sad part of the aspects
just feels really cheap like here let me
play this really sad song when I want
you to cry and it worked it worked it
like conditioned us like we were a
[__] dog to be like okay you hear the
belt or you cry now you cry what I would
recommend instead I think instead of
anaana is uh Maria the the mov yeah
because that's written by the same
person and I think Maria is just I think
is is the better aged version of anoh
God do you know what I think would be
interesting cuz I was I had this thought
the other day where you take a show like
anah or some other really popular show
uh and you do kind of like an after
Story of all of the characters grown up
right and just seeing just seeing where
like I I think K can you pull up the
anohana 10 years
later like they did they did a 10 years
later drawing and I saw it and I'm like
oh just give me like just give me one
like a Side Story don't know ready this
look look at this look at this look at
that poster oh my
God
yeah no click on the closeup my
babies can we see can we see a closeup
of this man he's got a
beard wa oh my God no no oh my no my
broke turned into a hippie man look at
the main character yo the guy on the
left is me for real
I oh I wasn't ready for that they're
like they're like salary men bro yeah I
know right in the fields man oh that's
just I will say like the [__] blueair
girl like be careful you who you make
fun of in high school man be careful of
who you make fun in high fun of in high
school they should have done an anime
from this age would have been more
interesting yeah I mean there's still
hope you know they might remake it who
knows yeah hopefully I mean I mean I
would I would not necessarily anaana but
I would love to see something like this
in general uh especially cuz all we get
is like the [__] what if official
collaboration pieces or what if fan arts
uh but I would love to see something
like that because I think that would be
absolutely incredible um all right going
back to the 3X3 though here's another
question I had for Sydney higashi now on
this 3x3 it's the recent remake
readaptation of it should have been the
original the original
put okay okay I wanted to ask are we
talking about the original here are she
yeah um I mean checks out she she loves
her horror so this is not surprising at
all and there is not a lot to pick from
for it's the most solid entry I'd say
the original one for sure yeah I can see
this one this is always the first horror
anime that got spread around just
because it was like so shocking that Q
girls could actually you know it's a
cutesy art style but actually they're
all murderous girls and there's blood
and there's go and it has one of the
most convoluted stories ever written in
horror yeah yeah yeah which I never I've
never finished the second season of
higashi which I know yeah no I liked it
I thought it was too slow really yeah in
the first season is too slow too I mean
I've played the original visual novel
and that is way slower than the anime so
yeah that's that that attract a certain
kind of person you know what's good
though the higashi manga is actually I
think more terrifying than the anime
because what they did with the higashi
manga which I really like cuz you know
how higashi split up into like different
sections I guess the story so what they
did in the manga was each section is
actually illustrated by different manga
artists oh that's actually kind of so
each section yeah so you actually when
you go through each section you actually
get completely different visuals and
different interpretations of that part
of the story and some of them are some
of the most terrifying manga panels I've
ever I cannot think about the show
without that scene from that documentary
where gu's like yeah today I researched
how much gas it would take to blow up a
school why what no
no there is this documentary on YouTube
following I think like the family that
was like making the visual novel game so
if you go to YouTube Type in like uh
Higurashi documentary it's actually a
pretty cool documentary them just
following the family that's makes it
right and uh the yuki7 right yeah yeah
yeah yeah and uh I don't know if it's
all dedicated to it but there is like
one scene where the old guy i s he looks
at his PC yeah he turns around he goes
well today for accuracy I had to I had
to figure out how much gas it would take
to blow up a school for one of the
scenes and I was like I don't I don't I
don't think you had to research that
well you needed to make it realistic
right I was like did that have any
bearing on the plot was like a question
that was like how much gas should we buy
guys oh yes yes officer that's that's
why being an author is just the best way
to how manys give yourself 629 629 VI
how the [__] you find that it was um I
think it's been re-uploaded a bunch it's
from an NHK program from 2005 there's no
way they uploaded in 60 FPS in 2005 I
don't know what the [__] why they did
that but yeah they basically followed
him and there's a scene where he's like
the old man yeah I think it's this one
yeah can you play it from here yeah yeah
I think it's like around here the father
who wants banned games is in charge of
background research
for one game I had to research and chart
volcanic gas
composition and for another I had to
figure out how much gas was needed to
blow up a
classroom I literally I literally cannot
think about this show without just
imagining an old man Googling how much
gas it takes to blow up a classroom I'm
surprised getting on some government
list I'm surprised I remembered that EX
what the exact scenario and I just I
have no idea hey man they had to make
sure it could be a real because remember
higashi you do not need to measure that
higashi is a mystery horror they has to
be realistic how did he calculate that I
don't know I'm sure there are on tan
probably yeah dude I I just can't reddit
reddit figure it out there's going to be
someone in the subreddit on this episode
but being like I figured out the gas
composition and how much you need needed
being like depends on the size of how
did you research that tell me like like
okay did you really need to research
that I don't know I've never want seen
an explosion a piece of media and
thought no no was doesn't seem right hey
man some authors want the believability
of their story to be watertight but it's
just the fact that it's the whole family
producing it and it's the father it's
just the old this old man he's just
sitting there looks dead pen on the
camera today I had to research how to
blow up a school it's a dead like what
dead pan voice over that [__] kills
me yeah it's so good it's so [__]
funny but yeah good choice I think for a
horror anime um what on Earth is this uh
Kami
Kamen kamiak I've heard Sydney talking
about this I've never seen it myself
this is like a Saturday Night Live
parody of anime the eyes are so
monstrously big is that there is one
scene or one uh clip uh screenshot that
got really really memes and it's the one
where it's like search up search up kich
Karen eyes and I'm sure it's got to be I
know which one you're talking about yeah
yeah where she looks like a [__] bug
where
that's
yeah wait this this looks like my
drawings of characters everybody thinks
this is an edit but this is actually in
the episode the episode because this is
what the arar was in the early 2000s
[__] this is the uh
mid 2000s how to draw anime art book
yeah art oh there's also Cannon
as what the [__] is the plot of the show
I don't even know I think it's some kind
of magical girl show from the of it it
looks like a magical girl show
13-year-old Cy h on feels like her life
can't get any worse parents died when
she was young Jesus that was not how I
thought the show leaving her with an
aunt who doesn't hesitate to call her
stupid unless and useless over her Paul
gra God damn uh her only friend her cat
named xan passed away recently oh my God
she can't catch a break uh begins her
moment uh moment her life turns around
for the better when she is approached by
a girl who also has lost her parents and
her cousin who finds goals to be
Troublesome both of them searching for a
goddess her mother's momento ring brings
shines brightly in their presence and
fills her with its Radiance making her
smarter faster and capable of granting
wishes okay so it's like a mega
depressing magical girl spin I guess
godamn so why does why does uh Sydney
like I I don't know she uh so what the
[__] explain why she likes so that leads
into evangelon right I know but uh well
evang gilon is how you guys met right
evang gilon is how we met but also she
actually watched it because uh I showed
it to her and uh it really really
[__] connected with her I mean it's
[__] it's a legendary show for a reason
yeah so I would say Comm Karen
I don't know like I've talked to her a
lot about kamich Karen she she just
holds it close to her heart this this
must be like the that one nostalgic uh
you know guilty pleasure show that you
grew up with you know it's not the best
but you have a special place true with
it which is fair all right very fun
Leist either way very fun well now I
know next time I see a Sydney I'm going
to talk to her about B